katia est cependant c'est davantage
quand les circonstances de cette
fusillade
[Musique]
des coups de feu ont été tirés vers
13h45 devant l'hôpital henri dunant rue
michel-ange dans le 16e arrondissement
tout près de la porte de saint-cloud un
hôpital qui sert également actuellement
deux centres de vaccination un homme a
fait feu entre six et dix fois et c'est
balante atteint un homme et une femme
alors l'homme selon le témoignage d'un
propriétaire de brasserie était en train
de boire un café et a priori il a été
atteint de plusieurs balles y compris
lorsqu'il était à terre le conti ne tira
à continuer de faire feu donc l'acte
semble délibéré en ce qui le concerne
est malheureusement mort de suites de
ses blessures quant à la femme elle a
été grièvement atteint talent est
actuellement en urgence absolue est
traité dans l'hôpital henri dunant elle
est a priori en arrêt cardio
respiratoire on écoute un voisin témoin
de la fusillade
qu'est ce qui se passe dans nos
quartiers ne pas l'habitude de voir des
petites choses comme ça c'est
exceptionnel
depuis que j'avais essayé ça fait plus
de 40 ans que je vis aussi j'ai jamais
de le déposer à tout ça jordi
aujourd'hui avec tout ce qui se passe à
la télé bougez côté à boiko savent
aujourd'hui tex avery
le tireur a pris la fuite à scooter il
est simplement remonter sur son véhicule
sans plaque et il est parti on ne
connaît pas du tout et les raisons de
son geste le quartier est actuellement
bouquet vous pouvez voir derrière moi à
porte de saint cloud tandis que le maire
du xvième arrondissement francis szpiner
est venu sur place on va pas écouter sa
réaction et la vaccination continue lot
centre dunant pour l'ifop la population
qui inquiète il ne s'agit pas d'un
attentat terroriste
il ne s'agit pas d'un attentat contre le
centre de vaccination c'est
vraisemblablement un règlement côté nous
essayons de maintenir le rythme des
vaccinations et je rends hommage aux
personnels de la croix rouge qui se
conduit remarquablement la croix rouge a
envoyé un soutien psychologique eux et
les gens qui ont été choqués sont réunis
à l'hôpital
donc comme le maire le laisse entendre
il ne doit pas s'agir d'un acte
terroriste donc même si le quartier est
bouclé bien les personnes qui devaient
se faire vacciner entre au
compte-gouttes un donc les acteurs
médicaux se poursuit mais le quartier
évidemment sous le choc un les habitants
étant habitués à une ambiance ce très
paisible ici dans le 16e arrondissement
merci beaucoup katia technique